[Musique]
bien sûr c'est une pompe et crédits
qu'ils veulent sur le ballon
dans ce matin six patients sont partis
avec le tgv sanitaire des places sont
déjà quasiment tout plein à nouveau et
donc on a ceux ci on a rajouté encore
deux autres transferts vers l'allemagne
mais malgré cela on a du mal à trouver
de la place pour les patients en
réanimation
nous avons quelques jours d'avancé sur
le reste de la france et ce qui permet
de donner notre retour d'expérience à 6
milliards en centre afin qu'ils se
préparent
on n'est pas préparé à ce genre de
vagues on n'est pas préparé à cette
intensité et surtout à cette intensité
qui dure sur plusieurs semaines
ce qui fait que ça désorganise
totalement non seulement les services
mais l'ensemble de l'établissement et de
ce fait il faut se réorganiser en
permanence
le plus dur c'est de ne pas savoir ce
qui va se passer demain c'est de ne pas
savoir combien de patients vont être mis
sous respirateur artificiel c'est de ne
pas savoir combien de places vont être
disponibles et malgré toutes nos nos
anticipations
on a l'impression d'être toujours en
retard d'une voire de deux cases par
rapport à la réalité de terrain
il faut pas se leurrer les épidémies de
ce type l'un elles vont se répéter
elles vont revenir dans les années
prochaines ça ne pourra plus être comme
avant il y avait un avant kobe durant un
après covin j'espère simplement que les
conclusions de la préco vite seront
suffisamment forte et courageuse pour
nous permettre de repartir sur des bases
saines pour un certain nombre de
décennies
[Musique]